it's perhaps an unwanted reminder of all
the cash flows and the business dealings
that underpin the global vaccine rollout
but it is a reminder of course that this
is essentially
a business that needs to be kept afloat
and pharmaceutical companies are out
to make a profit whether it's a large
profit or a small small profit
and of course that raises a whole raft
of different ethical questions as well
but
according to the latest contract between
fisa moderna
and the european union there will be a
price hike for their
shots uh in the imminent future
according to uh
figures seen by the financial times the
new price for a fighter shot will be 23
dollars up from 18.
moderna will go up to 25.50 up to
up from 22.60 this of course says eu
countries are very
keen and anxious to stamp out uh the
spread of the
delta variant also comes at a time in
which uh countries
in the eu and beyond the eu are mulling
the possibility
of administering a third dose a booster
jab to improve efficacy so far only
israel has approved use of a third dose
a booster jab
in the over 60s we know that research is
happening
here in the uk and britain and other
countries may well follow suit and all
of this
of course means a potential uh windfall
for both
moderna and pfizer as well
after phase three trials both of these
vaccines have been proven to be more
effective than their rivals than the
astrazeneca
uh jab and the johnson and johnson jab
so essentially
both of these companies have a captive
audience in the european union
the european commission just to remind
you of course was accused early on of
not acting quickly enough
when it came to the vaccine rollout and
what it's doing now is proving that it's
willing to
throw an awful lot of money at buying a
premium
product that is proven to work across
the board
according to one figure who was close to
the negotiations
said he said that the companies had
capitalized on their market power
and deployed the usual pharma rhetoric
essentially the vaccines work time to
ramp up the price
you